if you are a nerd like me
you often have to skip stage three
because you'd like the intuitive empathy
with others because in order to resonate
with a group you need to have a quite
similar architecture and if people are
wired differently then it's hard for
them to resonate with other people and
basically have empathy which is not the
same as compassion but it is a shared
perceptual mental state empathy happens
not just via inference about the mental
states of others but it's a perception
of what other people feel and where
they're at can she not have empathy
while also not having a similar
architecture cognitive architecture as
the others in the group I think yes but
I experience that too but you need to
build something that is like a meta
architecture you need to be able to
embrace the architecture of the other to
some degree also find some common ground
and it's also this issue that if you are
a nerd no means often so people is in
neurotypical people have difficulty to
resonate with you and as a result they
have difficult the understanding you
unless they have enough wisdom to to
fear what's going on there well aren't
we in the whole process of the stage
there is to figure out the API to the
other humans that have different
architecture and you yourself publish
public documentation for the API
that that people can interact with for
you isn't this the whole process of
socializing my experiment as a child
growing up was that um I did not find
any way to interface with the stage
three people and they didn't do that
with me so okay yeah of course they
tried it very hard but it was only when
I entered the mathematics school at
ninth grade lots of other nerds were
present
um that I found people that I could
deeply resonate with and had the
impression that yes I have the friends
now I found my own people and before
that I felt extremely lonely in the
world there was basically nobody I could
connect to
and
I remember
um there was one moment in all these
years where I was in there was a school
exchange and it was the Russian boy kid
from the Russian garnison station in
Eastern Germany you visit our school and
we played a game of chess against each
other and we looked into each other's
eyes and we sat there for two hours
playing this game of chess and I had the
impression this is a human being he
understands but I understand
we didn't even speak the same language
I wonder if uh your life could have been
different if you knew that it's okay to
be different to have a different
architecture
whether like accepting that
the interface is hard to figure out
takes a long time to figure out and it's
okay to be different in fact it's
beautiful to be different
it was not my main concern my main
concern was mostly that it was alone
right this was not the so much the
question is it okay to be the way I am
the I couldn't do much about it so I
have to do I have to deal with it but um
my main issue was that I was not sure if
I would ever meet anybody growing up
that I would connect to at such a deep
level that I would feel that I could
belong so there's a visceral undeniable
feeling of being alone yes and I noticed
the same thing when I came into the math
school that I think
at least half probably two-thirds of
these kids were severely traumatized as
uh children growing up and in large part
due to being alone
because they couldn't find anybody to
relate to don't you think everybody's
alone deep down no huh
I'm not alone anymore it took me some
time to update and to get over the
traumata and so on but I felt that in my
20s I had lots of friends and I had my
place in about and it was I had no
longer doubts that I would never be
alone again
is there some aspect to which We're
Alone Together you don't see a deep
loneliness inside yourself still no
sorry
okay so that's the non-linear
progression through the stages I suppose
you caught up on stage three it's stage
four and so basically I find that many
Nerds jump straight into stage four
bypassing stage three did they return to
it then later yeah of course sometimes
they do not always
yeah the question is basically do you
stay a little bit Autistic or do you
catch up and I believe you can catch up
you can build this missing structure
yeah and
um I basically experience yourself as
part of a group learn intuitive empathy
and develop the sense this perceptual
sense of feeling what other people fear
and before that I could only basically
feel this when I was deeply in love with
somebody and visitor so there's a lot of
friction to feeling that way like it
takes it only with certain people as
opposed to It comes naturally yeah it's
frictionless but um this is something
that basically later I felt started to
resolve itself for me to a large degree
what was the trick
in many ways growing up and paying
attention
meditation the tab I had some very
crucial experiences
um in getting close to people building
connections
um
cuddling a lot in my student years
so really paying attention yeah to the
what is it to this
feeling another human being fully loving
other people and being left by other
people and so building a space in which
you can be safe and can experiment and
um touch a lot and be close to somebody
a lot and over that over time basically
at some point you realize oh it's no
longer that I feel locked out but I feel
connected and I experience where
somebody else is at and normally my mind
is racing very fast at high frequency so
it's not always working like this
sometimes works better sometimes it
works less but also don't see this as a
pressure it's more it's interesting to
observe myself which frequency I'm at
and uh at which mode somebody else is at
yeah man the mind is so beautiful in
that way sometimes sometimes it comes so
natural to me so easy to pay attention
pay attention to the world fool each
other people fully and sometimes the
stress
over silly things is overwhelming it's
so interesting that the mind is that
roller coaster in that way